voilà tactique qui a donc visiblement
cette fois porter ses fruits
donnera-t-elle de l'élan aux forces
ukrainiennes jusqu'où ira cette percée
les ruse pour être à leur tour
pourrait-il à leur tour contre-attaquer
je me tourne vers vous gauthierrabbinsky
bonjour on tente de décrypter ce qui est
en train de se jouer évidemment à l'Est
mais aussi au sud de l'Ukraine on parle
beaucoup forcément aux conditionnel
quand on commente ce conflit malgré tout
il y a de vrais certitudes qui event à
remporter des succès ces derniers jours
a remporté des succès dans la mesure où
on peut les constater notamment par
l'observation satellitaire et par des
drones également alors on va voir ça sur
une carte parce que au début en fait
cette offensive était prévue sur heerson
et puis finalement il y a eu donc une
ruse de la part de l'armée ukrainienne
qui a déployé voilà la carte qui a
déployé son effort de manière à ce que
personne souhaite une sorte de fixation
pour les troupes russes qui sont isolé
relativement isolé dans cette région
mais les combats bien sûr ont eu lieu
t'es pas majeure et surtout pour aller
tout en haut à raquif dégager rakif du
de l'étau russe et progresser vous le
voyez vers isomesum qui est carrément
dans la partie régie par les républiques
fantômes sont au proclamés de luanski et
Donetsk favorable donc Horus et à partir
de là mettre un pied à isium c'est
mettre à nouveau il y a aussi crémators
mais c'est mettre à nouveau un pied dans
les défenses de ces armées fantômes qui
sont en réalité soutenues par les
troupes russes et de pouvoir faire en
sorte qu’éventuellement il y ait le
moyen de frapper c'est un peu la
tactique habituelle maintenant de
frapper les troupes russes n'ont pas
directement le premier rideau mais avec
les missiles comme ceux de high mars qui
sont des missiles américains ou bien les
les canons César de pouvoir frapper
au-delà des premières lignes russes pour
atteindre les entrepôts les la
logistique et le carburant ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que vous avez régulièrement
des troupes ukrainiennes qui récupèrent
du matériel russe
non seulement bien sûr les armes mais
aussi du matériel lourd des chars des
transports de blindés de troupes qui
sont intactes parce que leur servant
leurs occupants russes les ont quittés
n'ayant plus de carburant et surtout
étant profondément et scellé parce
qu'ils n'ont pas non plus de
commandement direct qu'il les tient
informés de ce qui se passe les Russes
qui ont eux-mêmes admis reconnu
officiellement avoir perdu du terrain ça
c'est une sacrée étape non oui alors
reconnaissent pas forcément avoir perdu
du terrain et ils disent qu'ils se
redéploie et qu'il se retire là où c'est
très intéressant c'est que vous aviez
dans le domaine de la propagande et de
l'information jusqu'à présent un bloc
notamment avec des personnages qui
œuvrent à la télé et que nous montrent
souvent helenavolochine ces personnages
aujourd'hui sont un peu
dispersés le message est moins compact
certains disent qu'il y a eu
effectivement des villes reprises par
les Ukrainiens d'autres se refusent à le
faire vous avez une personne comme
Magali tassimonian qui est le la
directrice de Spoutnik et de le château
des qui est une propagande
on dirait presque et serveur
de haine et qui refuse la moindre once
de vérité et bien cette fois elle dit
peut-être qu'il faudrait essayer de
retrouver ce qui fait notre unité à nous
autres
ukrainien et russes
kaderhov ramzankhadirof le maître prorus
là aussi fantoche de la Tchétchénie qui
s'en prend maintenant à shoegout le
ministre de la Défense en disant ce type
là n'a rien compris les erreurs lui
incombe vous voyez il y a des
craquelures il y a des fissures et puis
alors là aussi il y a quelque chose
qu'il faut saluer parce que nous le
faisons régulièrement mais la la
résistance de certains russes vous avez
des membres d'un conseil municipal de
Saint-Pétersbourg qui ont écrit une
lettre ouverte en disant Vladimir
Poutine nous conduit à l'abîme il
mériterait d'être jugé pour trahison et
surtout sa guerre nous entraîne à une
énorme régression nous sommes à nouveau
haïs et tout cela n'est pas bon pour la
Russie vous imaginez ce que ces gens en
cours sous un régime tel que Poutine ils
encourt au minimum 15 ans de prison et
ça c'est intéressant parce que ça prouve
notamment la craquelure côté russe mais
ça prouve aussi que il y a des voix qui
sont hardissent alors qu'elles ne sont
hardissait pas d'un mot pour terminer
vous me posiez la question d'une
possible contre-offensive russe dans ces
conditions avec les pertes que les
Russes ont subi cela nécessite
probablement de procéder une
mobilisation générale mais la
mobilisation générale qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire d'abord c'est difficile à
organiser politiquement c'est surtout
destructeur ça voudrait dire que la
direction russe admet enfin que la
situation est mauvaise et quand on fait
une obligation générale ça s'appelle
plus une opération spéciale ça s'appelle
la guerre merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
Gauthier